going let's do in sinner or try one of
these new characters you like the blue
and black and sooner all nice you got to
figure out how to do that move where he
throws him into the into the ropes of
the ring yeah so small we're gonna be
compared to Bowser I don't know why just
seeing him like in his little picture
you think of him as big all right so
that's his be attack down be is that
some kind of parry does he have anything
with fire oh I got a mushroom I thought
I just did something - whoa Howser man
yikes decimated right there
all right let's try to figure out its
attacks Ganondorf another big character
it's like a wrestling theme here
okay I think that is his oh that's his
forward be attack right there just
regular beat is that where I like spin
around like that and then down be see if
it's a parry
oh it's a parry nice and now look at him
it's like he has some kind of I mean I'm
powered up or something
[Music]
dude he's strong I'm knocking these guys
out pretty early and they're heavy
characters nice play take it up to 6.5
team battle Morton in Ludwik round three
whoa chaos that's a really cool move I
like that
then try to parry again and see if it
see if that like read those flames come
on me again
I missed at that time because there's so
many items going on I don't know if it
was an item or if it actually came from
from me carrying that attack against
Ganondorf
long get that assist trophy out there
the Chain Chomp
there we go he's pretty cool so far I'm
liking it surprised he doesn't have any
flame attacks though he's any part fire
like part fire pokemon wearing the that
belt
would that you can fly that is a sweet
move
that says a upsmash right there up smash
on the ground down smash is a back-air
is like a little back kick right there
forward air is the what do you call that
kick dude why can I not think of that
when you use both leg drop kick
drop kick that's what I'm looking for
[Applause]
his forward B is the whole thing where
he grabs him throws him into the
turnbuckle down B is the parry just a
regular B is the spin so no fire text
that I can find see if I can parry DKR
oh it does okay
the parry give gave me that fire see if
I can parry him again oh I wonder if you
have to parry him like a certain number
of times before you maybe you like power
up or something I'm gonna lose this
fight if I keep messing around
what was bad is that the star
there we go maybe it's a tax get
stronger when you uh Perry and he turns
red I bet if you do it one more time I'm
like picturing heat maybe he like lights
up with flames and does even more damage
into the turnbuckle
Oh No was that I used my up B and then
it like launched me back off man that
was the best side done - I was over
eight in terms of difficulty let me try
this again huh
it's up B is interesting like he
launches and then he kind of goes down
at an angle and that the time that I
went off I think I just held held it in
the different burning pro-wrestling
spirit bonus game
trying to take my time more this time
because I think you actually have plenty
of time before the whatever the void
catches up to you
[Music]
there we go
yeah it is a little sad it's kind of
weird to there's no variety to the bonus
level just the same every time oh yeah
this is the one where I think you have
to hurry
to get through why can't I just destroy
that don't have time I think you can
destroy it but now those you cannot
destroy there the solid green I'm super
curious to know what happens if you keep
parrying attacks with him okay now see
this time master and in crazy hand I
don't get it I guess you just switch it
up give you some variety when you uh
based so much character you're using and
maybe how well you're doing in the level
- I don't know uncie this time I gotta
help her grip ninja here to help out
which the help is much welcome nothing
else at just even if he doesn't do any
damage to them it's gonna help give me
some distraction is he just sitting
there what wow do you Wow
man you got both of us of that one
oh crap dude
there goes greninja
man it's hard to dodge come on come on
come on we can do this
what okay how do you dodge that I guess
you got to do the air dodge right when
it gets to you
goodbye master hand and crazy hand
yikes yikes
you're next Oh bro there we go I'm gonna
have to play some more within center or
though I like him it's pretty cool I'm
wondering if on that turnbuckle attack I
think I'm supposed to actually follow it
up Mike after he throws him into the
turnbuckle then they come back I think
I'm actually supposed to hit them there
and do something else
instead of just letting them kind of
bump into him actually I might hop in a
training real quick just to try that
also to see if I can get them I think in
training mode you can have them attack
you like just do a little punch least
you could in the old ones then I can
parry a couple times and see what it
does when he oh yeah see look at that
like in the little picture there
it's like he's all powered up with the
flames